so this talk it's gonna explore two
libraries as our and hdf5 both of these
libraries solve a very similar problem
so the goal of this talk is to help you
kind of understand the places where they
differ so that you can make an informed
decision on which one of these libraries
to use for yourself so hopefully
everyone here has heard of at least one
of these libraries if you've heard of at
least one you will understand a lot
about the other one because they're
extremely similar but just kind of is a
refresher or if you haven't heard of
either of these gonna cover some of the
core shared concepts between these
before diving into the differences so
the most important thing is that it's
our and hdf5 are designed to handle
multi-dimensional data so if you're used
to modeling your data with num pyre is
that's kind of a model you want to think
of not so much pandas dataframes you
couldn't store you know a 1d array or a
2d array but it's really designed to
scale up to like three or four D so in
this example imagine you've got some
weather sensors and you're collecting
temperature and precipitation readings
from around the world to identify any
scalar data point in this data set you
would need to know what the reference
time is the longitude and the latitude
and then the field that you're
collecting so in this case you would
have a four dimensional data set you'll
notice that I've not drawn a four
dimensional data set on the slide
because I do not know how to do that the
other kind of important concept that
both hdf5 ends are are trying to cover
is that they're designed to store a lot
of data which means that you're going to
want to use compression in short terms
is it in a compressed form compression
is the same information taking up less
space there's generally two kinds of
compression lossless where you can
recover exactly the same information and
lossy both hdf5 ends are support both of
these kinds of compression and then
finally in order to get compression
you're basically going to try to look
for patterns in the data and like
calming them up or various other things
I don't know what time that compression
but when you lose when you compress data
is the ability to do random access so if
you have a big multi dimensional data
set it's very nice that you can get any
scalar value in constant time by just
applying an index or along every axis
once you've compressed the data you can
no longer do that
where the values live after you've done
all your compression so this means that
if you wanted to access a scalar data
point if you stored all your data in one
big blob that was compressed you'd have
to decompress the whole thing and index
into it what chunks do is they say
instead of storing the data in one big
blob what if you broke it up into little
blobs based on the semantic space so in
this case we've got a nine by nine data
set we chosen to break it up into little
three by three data sets we can then
compress each of these blocks separately
and store them after compression
separately so now if we knew that we
wanted to access the data point at zero
zero we would only need to load this
little three by three piece and
decompress it the way you choose the
shapes of the chunks and the size of the
chunks really depends on how you're
gonna access the data so in this 2d case
imagine we always wanted to read an
entire column at once in that case then
we should probably choose a chunk that
holds the entire column in one
allocation that gets compressed together
and then decompress together
if you always need a row we would do the
same thing with just a row this type of
chunking would be good if maybe we we
need a data point in all of its
neighbors but not much more than that
I'm not gonna cover exactly how you
should pick that there's a lot of good
posts on that and information about that
but both SAR & hdf5 support the same
kinds of chunking so that's not really a
difference between these two libraries
just in short compression is a trade-off
between the ability to do random access
in your data set and the compression you
get so if you want to store smaller file
you're gonna have slower random access
there's another way to think of that is
a throughput versus latency so if your
goal is just to read entire data set in
memory you shouldn't use chunking you
should just compress the whole thing in
one big block read the smallest amount
of data into memory and then use it but
if you want to be able to access small
data points very quickly then you
probably should choose smaller chunks
this lets us reduce i/o and we can cache
the the different blocks without holding
the entire data set memory at once hd5
inns are also supports storing more than
one data set in a single file so instead
of storing just one multi-dimensional
five data set you can store a tree that
resembles a positive
file system so you'll notice that the
file starts with a slash kind of like
the Linux or Mac file system inside that
you can store data sets and groups
groups can then store more data sets in
groups and this nests probably to some
reasonable computer limit but
conceptually infinitely some some terms
a data set is the name for one of these
multi-dimensional arrays that lives as
the leaves in your tree a group is a
collection of data sets or more groups
recursive and a know it is either a data
set or a group every node in the tree
can also have Associated arbitrary key
value data this is a property of node so
both data sets and groups can have this
and so are stores this in a JSON format
hdf5 stores it in a binary format but
it's basically arbitrary key value data
if you want to interface with our hdf5
from Python we're gonna use there's two
libraries for interfacing with hdf5
there's pie tables and h5 pie this talk
is gonna all cover h5 pie because it has
a near identical interface to czar as we
will see
so the general concepts and the python
air phases of these two libraries is
that you have a collection of nested
dictionaries to represent your tree the
keys of the dictionary are strings which
are the components of the group names or
the data set names and the leaves of
this tree or array like objects what I
mean by array like is that they're not
themselves numpy arrays but you can pass
anything that you could pass into the
brackets of an umpire a you can pass
into the brackets of these leaves so you
can like pass a boolean mask or an
integer indexers scalar numbers along
all the dimensions and so on these
objects also have a dot d type attribute
that tells you what the numpy D type of
this thing is and they have a dot shape
attribute that tells you the shape so
you can kind of think of them like numpy
arrays and yet again this describes h5
pi this is not how pi tables represents
the data to show kind of opening a file
ends are new boards our calls are not
open pretty straightforward you'll
notice that this returns a group object
so the file itself is also a group
it's the route group because there's no
parents of this if we want to put a data
set into this file we can assign into it
like a dictionary with numpy array in
this case it's a 20 by 5 array of
integers and if we're ever gonna so that
we don't read back out the original
array we get back this array like object
which in this case this is our core
array we can see the path to this thing
we can see the shape 20 by 5 and we can
see it holds in 64 we can also pass it
stuff into the in square brackets which
we could do it on 5 importantly though
every time you access it it's gonna do I
owe probably with some caching behind
the scenes but maybe not so if you just
want to load the data into an umpire a
to do lots of processing you can index
with a colon to copy it so the last
thing actually gives us an umpire array
with the same contents this is the same
code but with h5 pi so I'm just gonna
kind of show it a few times we've
changed two lines of code the first line
is in port h5 pi and the second line is
h5 PI dot file instead of czar not open
the wrappers are different but the same
information is they're slightly
different encoding so they pretty much
have a drop it in your drop-in
replacement with an API with the python
api some extra functionality not shown
here every node has an adders property
that is a dictionary like object to get
access to that key value store group
objects have a method called create data
set and this is how you should actually
create data sets pretty please never do
that array assignment thing I just
showed that will store the entire array
in one chunk with no compression which
may be from I like a little 20 by 5
thing that would be fine but if you're
using Tzar hdf5 that's probably not fine
so this method lets you pass the chunk
shape and compression and a few other
parameters the signature is almost
identical between Tzar and HD if I this
h5 PI as well
there's also create group to create
subgroups and data sets have a method
called
redirect this is what it's called an h5
pi it's got a much more verbose name and
czar that I can't remember it's like get
basic selection or something and what
this lets you do is read memory into an
existing buffer without allocating so
this is an important API to look at if
you are doing some high-performance
reads so the libraries model the same
things
they have basically the same height on
your face how would you choose to use
one versus the other so we're gonna
start covering some of the differences
between these so first hdf5 is over 20
years old h25 is almost as old as I am
it has excellent cross language support
so hdf5 can be used with in Fortran C C
sharp C++ Java go any language that you
would deploy to production you can use
HD 5 with of course I thought as well
because it's really old and has really
good cross language support there's a
lot of existing software that exists so
kind of two things I would say
immediately disqualifies our or if you
know that you're gonna need to use the
data set from within a C++ program
already or you are currently consuming a
program that uses hdf5 that's not
written in Python then you probably
should not like it's our HD 5 is gonna
be really good for that that use case
and Tsar doesn't currently have anything
to handle that well
issue 5 itself is written in C and in my
opinion it's one of the cleanest like
most easy to read code bases it's all
object-oriented code in C and has
structured exception handling it's like
we're dialect but very well documented
like well commented pretty easy to
follow what's going on HD 5 can be made
thread safe so by default it is not
thread safe meaning you cannot do
concurrent access to the same file from
the same process you can compile HD 5 to
be thread safe but as the doc say thread
safe does not mean thread optimal
all thread safety does is it adds locks
to the code so that it serializes access
to the file it does not actually make it
like work in parallel I think you can do
it through an MPI driver but it's much
harder to use and means you have to be
using MPI and then HD 5 because it's in
C can be extended in C so we can extend
the functionality with plugins czar on
the other hand was first released in
2015 and the window release was sometime
in 2016 so it's much much newer it's
written in Python it's pure Python uses
numpy but other than that I think
there's no native code and czar and I
would say that at least for now it's
very much Python oriented it's like
designed to be consumed from Python
with and like Python ecosystem in mind
however it does have a reasonable
specification that could be
reimplemented and has been reimplemented
in c++ i don't know how stable that that
implementation is but it is possible and
is our team is working on making that
more of a spec than than a Python code
artifact so this will probably improve
in the future as our village have
multi-threading support which my opinion
is really important based on kind of the
way you configures R you can make it
actually access files concurrently and
because R is written in Python and as
Python oriented you can extend it in
Python so when I say that you can extend
both hdf5 in Tzar what I mean there's
really two classes of extensions that
you can write filters and compressors
and storage backends and we're gonna go
into those in detail in just a second so
when you try to make your choice you
really should look at which extensions
do the libraries actually come with so
which of these filters and compressors
and storage backends are you just gonna
get out of the box how easy is it for
you to write your own filter compressor
or storage back-end for a non-default
use case and how easy is it to
distribute these these extensions and
distribute can either mean distributing
your plugin to other people or consuming
a plugin that maybe someone else has
written already
the first kind of plugin we're going to
talk about our filters compressors are a
subtype of filter so a filter is a
function that sits between the users
semantic data and the storage layer so
these are like compression so user wants
to write some data to disk they've got
their big array they feed it through a
compressor they get compressed data
compressed data makes it to storage and
then on the other side the user would
like to read the data data comes into
the filter a compressed
gets decompressed and then pass back to
the user so filters get attached to data
sets and this means that the user does
not actually need to think about
compression every time they read or
write to a data set they set it up once
when they set up the data set and then
after that every read and write will go
through your code
kind of transparently to the user
another type of filter is check
something so if you want to be sure that
you've read from disk the data you wrote
you may want to have had a little
checksum like an md5 or our Fletcher 32
type check so that when you read the
data back in memory you're like yeah
there's no issues with the disk or
whatever it didn't get messed up filters
are also composable so you could run a
lossless compression into a checksum and
then write that data to disk make sure
you read back the right data then
decompress it there's other types of
filters that are not necessarily
compressors by themselves but help
compressors so imagine like a delta
encoder where instead of storing the
value Z store just the disk between the
values you may want a delta encode and
then pass that into a compressor because
you think that would get better
compression for your data set all
filters act one chunk at a time so when
you do your i/o
to the storage it's always acting in the
unit of an entire chunk so we're gonna
read the whole chunk and we're gonna
write the whole chunk every time kind of
visualize this we've got our user data
they want to write it passes through the
filter let's say it's compression we're
gonna compress it we're gonna send it to
storage on the other side the data will
move back when they compose though the
user maybe wants to do Delta encode
compress checksum right and then on the
way back we're gonna first check the
checksum decompress undo the deltas so
it will kind of run in reverse order
the default filters that come in hdf5
are LZ f gz s if a zip is a compression
library developed by nasa i've the docs
say that has some patent issues i've
never need to use it does exist scale
offset which is a floating-point
compression thing that's lossy shuffle
is one of these things that kind of
augments another compressor so it works
by shuffling all the bytes within a
block to try to get the longest run
lengths that it can and then it stores
the kind of transpose and then fletcher
32 is a checksum and with h 5 pi you can
compose shuffle fletcher and one of the
compressors but i don't actually think
you can do a custom pipeline but that
might be coming on the other hand tsar
comes with
of compressors or filters out of the box
when I say to fall filters and czar what
I mean Tsar actually broke out all of
its filters into a different library
called mom codex and the idea was that
maybe you want to use these filters but
you don't actually want to download czar
or use or you just want to use these
algorithms some important things to note
it has blask
as a default option velasca is a very
popular and really efficient library for
compression it's designed to make an
optimal trade-off between reading less
data into memory and the cost to
actually decompress it so it's optimized
for time to getting the decompress data
into memory it also has some useful
things like categorical encoding so it
basically implements the same algorithm
is PD categorical where you can store
just the unique strings and then indices
into that JSON message pack and pickle I
bucketed into one thing because they let
you store kind of arbitrary Python
objects in your data structure might be
useful I would recommend not using
pickle if you had to do that though
and then v-line string would be if you
have variable length strings you can
also store vielen strings in hdf5 but
it's with a different type so you don't
do it as a filter transformation so
let's say you actually wanted to write
your own filter and hdf5
so like I said you extend hdf5 by
writing C code it's okay
you don't write C code I'll try to walk
through it try to stay high level so
function is gonna take as parameters
flags which is gonna be a bit mask NL
and values which is gonna be an array of
integers that are user defined
parameters so let's say we've got a
compressor with a compression level like
you know blocks takes compression level
from 0 to 9 like how much of a trade-off
you want to spend on space versus time
these are kind of like your user fine
options
notice that the user fine options all
have to be integers and unsigned
integers of that so you don't have a lot
of flexibility with the kinds of
parameters you can give to a filter and
then the last three arguments are all
about the buffer that we're gonna be
acting on so remember the buffer is one
chunk of data and this is gonna be of
size n bytes we've got n bytes of data
we have a pointer to a buffer so a
pointer to an array of stuff because it
slowly we don't know what's in it and
then this out parameter which we'll get
to in a second there are the two ways
that this works so this is a single
function interface that handles both
encoding and decoding or compression and
decompression or whatever operation you
need to do so the flags input will have
one bit called h5z h c does not have
namespaces h v says this is h v code z
says this is an operation or a value
that has to do with filters don't know
Xia's filter but that's how that main
space works and then the bit is called
flag reverse so if that bit is true then
we're decoding so we're saying if that
bit is not true we need to encode the
data the way encoding the data works is
that we're gonna read the buffer pointed
to by buff and we are going to try to
compress the data in place so we're
gonna try to shrink the data using that
same memory if possible because we're
compressing that should be possible and
if that's the case then we're just going
to return a size which is the number of
bytes in the original buffer and we're
going to write to this output pointer
how many bytes of semantic data we have
left so the buffer is 100 bytes we get a
50% compression ratio so we now have 50
bytes of data buff size will hold a
value of 50 and we will return 100 it's
that's confusing to you is confusing to
me so decoding on the other hand we've
likely cannot reuse that same storage
because we're going to make the data
bigger right so we have 50 bytes now and
we need to fill out 100 bytes so we
would do instead is allocate a new
buffer that's a hundred bytes then we
will free decompress into that buffer
call free on the thing pointed to by
buff and replace it with our new buffer
we're then going to set the two values
to be the same thing one last thing is
that you can return 0 which means that
your filter failed what failure in a
filter means is that for some reason
this filter could not be applied to that
so maybe you've got a compressor that's
like I'm gonna assume that most of the
blocks are gonna look like this like
they're absent maybe you have n64 data
because you might have some really large
ends but most of your data would fit in
in 32 so you might have write a filter
that says just trying to put it in 32
and see what happens if you have a value
that's too big for a name 32 you could
return zero and then what will happen is
hdf5 will just take your filter out of
the pipeline so if your filter is the
only thing it will take you to draw
input data and write it directly to
storage and it will mark that that
happened for this block and then on read
it will just read the deep like the non
compressed data if you have a big
pipeline it will just kind of skip that
one step another extension point is this
function can apply the two important
arguments are this type ID and a space
ID hid is this hdf5 object pointer
because it's object oriented type ID is
an object that refers to the D type of
the data
so is this an integer if given that it's
an integer is it little-endian or
big-endian how many bytes are is that
are in this integer things like that the
space ID is something that refers to the
shape of the block so is this a 64 by 64
block or whatever so you may write a
compressor that requires 2d data or 1d
data or blocks that have more than you
know a kilobyte in them or whatever and
you can decide you know given this block
I think this filter should just not
apply anyway and this returns a three
state variable so it can fail return
false or Archer next we're gonna define
an integer which is unique code that
refers to our our filter so when we
create a file that has one of these
custom filters in it and I send this
file to someone we would like to know
which filter was applied so we could
undo the transformation to do that we're
just gonna store this one unique integer
ID and the way we actually get this
integer is we email the HDF group and we
say hey I'm writing a new filter will
you please assign me a number and they
just send you back a number and they're
like sure this one's reserved for you
and what this means is that I don't
write a filter like let's say I write it
my my Delta encoder
and someone else writes the gzip thing
and we both choose to say well my folder
ID will just be 3,000 no one else will
want that and then I sent you the file
and you're like what
mm means gzip and then I try to like on
gzip decompress the data but I was
actually bill two encoded and it was
just nonsense so by having the central
authority you can kind of solve that
problem for development purposes though
there is a range of numbers that are
reserved for people who are writing
plug-ins before they're done with them
we're then gonna fill out this drugs
with a bunch of parameters about how
this compressor should work like do we
have an encoder and you can put decoder
which the filter function what's the can
apply function a few other things and
then we're gonna need to call h5z again
that's like the this is an H five
function about filters register and
we're gonna pass this V table so to
actually use this from H 5 PI we need to
somehow load this native code so the C
code into our Python process and here
I'm using standard library C types we
need to register our filter so I'm gonna
call this register function from C types
assert that it didn't fail and then I'm
gonna pull this integer out of the
binary so once you've done all this like
dark magic we can actually just pass
this integer as the compression
parameter at age five pi and it will
just work so we'll use our filter now
for doing compression for this thing
which is pretty cool so some
difficulties that you'll run into if
you're trying to write a custom filter
for HT of v h v pi by default
distributes binary wheels on linux
binary wheels are only allowed to
dynamically link to a small number of
libraries HT 5 is not in that list that
means that they statically like to hdf5
unfortunately H 5 PI through the way
that it gets loaded by Python does not
react sport this h5z register function
so you can't actually call the register
function from your extension by default
which is really annoying so what you get
around this is you don't use the binary
wheels and you recompile HT 5 when you
install it you can use this command I
will distribute these slides so people
can do this and what this says is I
actually would like to dynamically link
my age 5 pi against HD of 5 so that I
can then dynamically link my extension
against hdf5 and when I call register HD
of 5 H 5 pi
my extension both know about the same
h5z register function and will go on the
right place it's hard to thread
parameters to these things
I guess one difficulty it says you have
to write all this Seco and do all this
like DLL opening stuff which I didn't
consider when I read this as being a I
think but it's hard to throw the
parameters in and they have to be
integers so you don't have a lot of
configuration if your function needs
some state I don't know why you'd write
a state flow I think coder but maybe you
can get really good compression if you
do something like that you just have a C
function which can't close our any data
so it's just global State you have to
manage it yourself maybe more exotic
problem but a very real problem is that
when you allocate that buffer you have
to use Lib C malloc because the thing
that will free that buffer somewhere
deep in hdf5
is free this seems like it's fine if you
write your thing your filter in C but we
use C++ a lot where I work I prefer to
equals plus over just writing C and this
means that let's say I want to do like
some bit packing thing I want to use
boost dynamic bit set that's great but
it does not allocate its memory with
malloc so instead of returning a pointer
and a custom D allocator I have to
re-implement you know dynamic bits that
myself to make it use malloc which is
just a lot of hassle if you're trying to
write your extension in a different
language other than C and as far as I
can tell you can't use your filter in a
custom pipeline so you can feed your
filter into you can have shuffle happen
before your filter and then fletcher
happen after that but you can't compose
it with an existing compressor and then
this isn't really problem with just a
thing that consider is that they don't
trigger until flush so you don't know if
the code is going to succeed or not
until you actually flush it so the write
may appear to succeed before it gets
flushed some benefits though is it
because the filter ID the filter ID C is
a central authority so you're not gonna
run into any problems where you don't
understand how to open a file you can
pretty much tell for certain like I
don't know what this filter is I'm gonna
crash or I know this is filtered
whatever and I need to go load that and
actually skipping over there's a
directory a plug-in directory where you
can dump these shared objects and and
five will like no to go love them and
try to find which thing provides or
plugin because the filters are all
written in C and H D F and C has a lot
of bindings you can kind of use your
filters in any language that you would
want to open your file in yeah so
alternatively if you wanted to write a
filter in czar we would install them
codecs and import it and we're gonna
grab this codec class and then we need
to implement three functions or two
functions encode and decode so encode is
gonna take a Python buffer like object
and it's going to return the encoded
buffer and decode is gonna take the
buffer to decode and we'll return that
and it can also optionally take an
output buffer so this is gonna be
pre-allocated member memory that you
should write in to you also need to set
this codec ID which is a string unlike
an integer and that's gonna be kind of
unique thing that gets written into the
file so when we open this our file we
know what filter was used and then we
need to call register codec so this code
all fits on slide the other one like the
h5 London and then to use it in czar you
just import it like a Python object and
you can pass either compressor equals in
instance of your filter or you can pass
filters in a list and it's gonna they're
all gonna happen in the order to find in
that list and then for decompression
they're gonna run back through the other
way so some problems with these that
because there's no central authority I
can write a thing that doesn't
necessarily work with your filter and
then we both choose the same name and
now you get like corruption on reads
they require Python code so like I said
before walls czar has a spec that could
and has been implemented in other
languages not really a good way to make
your plugins work with that language so
yes I have my C++ implementation but I
can't open your filter because I don't
want to embed the Python interpreter in
my equals plus application or whatever
and this one maybe is controversial but
I think most compressors or filters are
gonna want to be written in native code
anyway like you're probably not writing
your new compression like like library
in Python so you probably want a native
code if you're doing anything custom
though I will say is a good point
so if someone has already provided
bindings for an existing thing that you
would just like to make czar aware then
you can you know kind of easily drop
that in because it's written Python you
can distribute your filters as a Python
package so that kind of solves that
problem as long as everything in your
ecosystem is using Python it's really
easy to pass parameters you can pass
constructor arguments to your class and
that's those will be the parameters your
filter managing state is very easy
because it's an instance of a class you
can store state right on itself one
thing to note is that the codecs must be
JSON serializable and there's a hook
that you can implement as part of the so
the base class here codec provides some
help to make things JSON to serialize
blow by default but you can override it
if you need to store things like a numpy
be type or or some other more
complicated my opinion having the API
split between encode and decode is far
more clear than just having a single
function interface and then you can
actually use filter pipelines in a very
clean way so I don't have time to go
through this whole example but to make
sure I understood all this correctly
while writing this talk I wrote a delta
delta filter which instead of starting
the deltas it stores the Delta Delta's
which is actually very good for things
where you have a regularly spaced sample
and the variation between the spacing is
small so this this will show how to do
it in both hdf5 and ZAR so you can
compare them yourself so the next type
of plugin that you might want to write a
storage so the idea of the storage
protocol is that storing the actual data
is not a concrete thing in either desire
or the HC fi spec so there's really no
single file type you can point so like
this representation of bytes on disk is
hdf5 and this's our there's like
different ways you can choose to store
these things there user configurable and
really there's two kinds of data that
you may need to store the first is of
course the user data so you yeah so the
question was coming was there
self-describing
in either case where I believe you mean
like
by self-describing do you mean like the
tree yeah so like how the data is
actually encoded you should be able to
recover as long as you use the same
driver or storage protocol to read the
thing that you wrote that's kind of the
only thing that you need to know but you
can't just try to look so maybe it
answer your question no you actually
need to know how to open the same file
there's nothing in the file that tells
you how to open it because it's so
abstract that I could write something
that just uses a totally different
protocol than another driver but they're
both hdf5 weather boats are so in the
file we store two kinds of data the user
data this is all of the things that make
up the multi-dimensional arrays and the
attributes that get stored in the tree
and then there's the metadata which is
the kind of a tree structure so all the
things that meat are needed to be stored
so that we know what are the groups and
what are the children of the group and
all of that stuff and then maybe any
extra information that we need to know
about that's specific to this storage
protocol would get stored somewhere
the hdf5 storage model is built on
what's called a virtual file driver and
the way this works conceptually is that
you've got one big contiguous memory
space so this is kind of like an
alligator so types of things that you
would need to implement are like grow
the memory space importantly there's no
shrink the memory space if you delete
data from hdf5 the file does not get
smaller
we'll never get smaller you just have to
copy it into like semantically copied
into a new file when you are writing the
the layer that actually handles all of
the i/o does not do anything about the
semantic data so you've got one big
memory space and you implement things
like write these bytes at this address
or we read 15 bytes at this address or
so on you don't actually know like is
this a chunk is this half of a chunk is
this metadata is it's the tree I don't
really know HD 5 is responsible for all
kinds of caching and locking so and it's
single threaded so you know that your
driver is always called a single
threaded context which is
kind of a problem in my opinion this is
our storage model on the other hand is
based because it's Python oriented it's
based on a basically a dictionary from
string to bytes any object that fulfills
the Python mapping are really the
mutable mapping protocol is a storage
driver for tar the key that gets passed
contains semantic information so you can
do transformations if you need to so for
example this key group / D set / 0.3
this is telling us that we are storing
data for a data set called D set inside
a group called group that's at the root
and we have two dimensional chunks and
this is the chunk chunk 0 along axis 0
and chunk 3 along axis 1 so this key
alone tells us a lot of information
about what data is being stored the
storage model or the the mapping object
is responsible for its own caching or
sorry locking you can have that sorta
like provide locking for you but you can
also handle your round locking and
importantly that means that you can do
multi-threaded access to the same data
because they're all built on mutable
mappings all of these objects are
composable so you could write for
example a storage mutable mapping that
says I'd like to store data set 1 on
disk and I'd like to store data set 2
like in memory because I don't actually
care about it's just a temporary or
whatever and you could build all of that
by composing an in-memory store and an
on disk star or doing more exotic things
if you need to the default storage
backends that come in hdf5 the first one
is called set to don't always call that
but it uses the POSIX file API to do
unbuffered access as a Windows driver
for using the windows file API stood i/o
for doing buffered C standard IO stuff
core which is in memory so the file will
just be used purely a memory stuff and
then family where it stores a directory
of blocks the family driver is strange
because it works by breaking up the
virtual contiguous memory space into
four gigabyte blocks and this is because
it's your 5 first camp who's out in 1998
where 64-bit file systems are not
and you wanted to be able to use a
64-bit virtual memory space on a file
system that could not support a single
file larger than four gigabytes so it
actually just lays out like here's the
first four gigs then the next four gigs
and you'll just kind of cap them
together through this driver and then H
five PI supports this driver called file
out which allows you to pass an
arbitrary Python file like object to H
five pi so you could hook write and read
using the Python protocol which is
pretty cool
Tsar has again like far more options
some interesting ones are that you've
got your memory store like I said before
with some cool ones or the s3 map and
the ABS store so these are dictionaries
that map blocks to s3
like Amazon s3 object storage or an ad
for blob storage so instead of having a
file located on disk you could pass
someone an s3 URI and they would be
downloading the chunks on demand and
then two that are really cool like I
mentioned because it's composable
instead of having czar manage block
caching for you you would instead
construct an LRU store cash around
whatever actual IO thing you wanted so
let's say you're reading data out of s3
it's very expensive to pull a block
you'd like to cache it you could create
an LRU store cache over an s3 map and
then the s3 map will pull the data and
then feed it to the seller you cash and
handle that for you and then
consolidated metadata store is a feature
that hdf5 supports but not a user
configurable way when you write a driver
you say do you want consolidated or not
and what this is is that all of the tree
structure can be stored in one big
allocation which will be read and
written in one big block so imagine
again you've got your like s3 storage
it's really expensive to pull any data
high latency you don't want to have to
make a lot of little reads just to
discover like what are the children of
this data set I'd like to iterate so you
can sense a try to store it all in one
big block and I will pull it all
together you don't need to make your
custom store know about that the
consolidated metadata store can look at
the keys parse out the semantic
information and then send new keys into
your map which is really cool
is
default if you're gonna use our I
recommend looking at the LM DB store it
is LM DB is a key value store it's
really efficient but I think there's
some licensing concerns to maybe look at
it and then otherwise the zip store is a
really good way to store a single file
on disk it stores it in a zip file where
each file is the block so if you want to
write a custom file driver and hdf5
you need to fill out this struct called
an h v FD so h DF v FD for file driver
class this is basically a big virtual
function table that tells us like how to
open and close the file and such so like
I said before right is gonna take a
bunch of arguments and then this h @ RT
this is the address we want to write to
a buffer this is the day where we want
to write and the size of that buffer so
it says hey put these bytes at this
address and importantly we don't know
like what these represent all of this
data is coming in after it's been
compressed or it's metadata so it's not
compressed we don't really know read has
the same API except the buffer is not
constitute into it and then we need to
fill out 28 more functions so the
functions are things like flush set yo a
set yo F chunky like all kinds of
basically like memory allocator slash
file IO type operations however each 5pi
doesn't actually support a nice Python
interface for registering drivers so we
don't have to run into an issue like we
had before so assuming you've packaged
your driver as a Python extension module
which is a whole other topic talked
about later
we will not talk about in this talk
though you need to implement this
function called set F APL which is the
file access property list once you've
implemented that you can pass H by PI
register driver you give it a name for
you some memory and then the function
and then when you construct a file you
can pass driver equals and then that
string key the path that's gonna get
passed is going to be just a string that
gets fed to your drivers open function
so in the s3 K or like let's say you
wrote a driver that did the same thing
where it's stored data and s3
maybe by blocking it up in like two
megabyte blocks or something instead of
maybe passing a path
to memory on file on disk you would pass
an s3 URI so this doesn't actually have
to be a file path as the first argument
is just a string that would be passed to
your drivers open and then any extra
keyword arguments that you passed a file
will be forwarded to the set file access
property list so yeah it's a pretty
reasonable support some problems with
this it's a huge API thing like I said
you have to implement all these
functions
there's no semantic information about
what's being stored it's really hard to
optimize because of that so let's say
you wanted to like break up data on disk
based on which data set it was in and
like maybe cache based on like the
chunks you don't know what you're
reading or writing so you can't make any
optimizations around the the data
they're not easily composable because
mmm
like issue 5 doesn't export these v
tables easily to you so you can't get
you know one drivers read or write
function and you have to like have the
library implement things like
consolidate data or caching for you you
can't write that as an API thing another
thing is that there's an ABI
incompatibility between versions 1/8 and
1/10 so hdf5 has two versions that are
being used in like commonly and while
those look like minor versions those are
actually major versions and they have
API incompatibilities so you'd have to
recompile your extensions for both 1/8
and 1/10 and it's single threaded so
imagine I talk you were doing that s3
case like I mentioned before reading
data is expensive you may want to do
that asynchronously
you cannot issue multiple asynchronous
reads from hdf5 so that's kind of like a
non-starter for anything where i/o is
going to be really expensive we see a
question today and I'm like I'm about to
run out of time so then one last thing
not many people have published file
drivers that I can see so there's not a
lot of like examples for like how do i
distribute these how do i write them the
good points this FA PL interface makes
it easy to thread arguments that are not
just integers they can be arbitrary data
types with custom allocators and
destructors really easy state management
the source so while not a lot of people
have written third-party drivers the
source code of the built-in ones are
really really nice like the SEC 2 driver
is extremely easy to read the family
driver also fairly easy to read these
can be built to minimize copy
so because the read interface gets past
the pre-allocated buffer to fill you
don't necessarily need to do a copy
every time you read you can read the
data right off disk into that buffer if
you are using stores that support that
type of operation because everything has
the same virtual contiguous memory space
you can potentially align all your
blocks together and then test a driver
by feeding it into another opening you
with another driver don't I'm just gonna
skip that we not a lot of time and then
it's also always a 64-bit memory space
not necessarily an interesting point
today but definitely amazing that they
decided to do that in 1998 like really
good stuff so to write a custom storage
back in Anton's are on the other hand we
don't need to import anything from sorry
important mutable mapping from
collections dot ABC in the standard
library we need to implement five
functions get items set item delete item
and an eater and Len
so all very basic Python stuff nothing's
our specific one big problem with this
api's will notice the get item just
takes the key and the storage acts one
chunk at a time so imagine I've got a 1d
data set chunks are length 10 and I
would like to read a hundred elements
from this data set and my date maybe my
read is perfectly aligned on the first
chunk so with HT 5 I would pass my my
buffer of size 100 into the read call
any would each piece would fill in the
output over that different disjoint
slice with zoar on the other hand I'll
have my big buffer of output allocated
and then every time I call get I'm gonna
get a newly allocated buffer of length
10 and then I have to copy it 10 bytes
at a time into this buffer so you
actually have to do a copy on every
single chunk for a read is this a big
deal probably not I would say most
drivers are going to be dominated by
just fetching the data into memory and
doing a copy like mmcd of one block at a
time
not really a big deal but this is thing
you might need to profile probably
reasonable to ask them to make a change
to like add an extension API we talk to
people about that it's really the only
problem I have with it the beauty of
these are that they're composable
you can do user-defined caching so the
youth like you as a library extender can
do a lot more stuff you have semantic
information to make more powerful
optimizations and transformations and
they're written Python where I thought
filters will most likely want to be
written in native code or use native
code somewhere because storage backends
are super i/o bound like the overhead of
the Python code is really not
significant and then one last thing
which I don't think I mentioned is
because it uses the mapping protocol
things can be used as our storage
backends that were not written furs are
like s3 map that I mentioned earlier is
not like written to be used as a czar
back-end but he can become as our
back-end so while you have to settle
with this copying issue which is maybe
not a big deal
you actually unlock all these great
storage backends that were not
specifically designed for its are so
some takeaways so he's got a lot of
modern features it's actively developed
the devs are really responsive and
helpful every issue I've opened has been
like addressed quickly people have
talked to me about how is using czar and
like want to make sure they understood
my use cases it's Python focused or
really like Python specific star because
actively working on changing that or
making it more language agnostic and I
say it's much easier to prototype
extension so even with filters writing
them as a prototype in Python it was
pretty nice HD 5 on the other hand is
really stable code and it's mature a lot
of people use it great cross language
support very single threaded if you want
to write a custom driver that would like
a synchronous stuff you're out of luck
and it's harder to write extensions at
least for most people who've got a PI
data so these are some links to my
github the example from before a
implementation of a file driver for hdf5
and uses s3 and those break up the
memory space I will say I would not
recommend using it in the process of
writing this I found the dangerously
single threaded problem to make this
really not suitable for production so
it's interesting is a learning exercise
not really for production thank you very
much
[Applause]
the question is is there an HDFS storage
back-end furs are and if not could it be
done if there's a mapping protocol
interface to HDFS then yes I do not know
the answer to that could it be done
probably there's a library that s3 map
is built on which is basically this like
generic file system like library it's
not fused but it's basically like
extractions over file systems and so
they have a map adapter for files
arbitrary file system so probably so the
so you store one key at a time so
however you want to choose to do that so
yes so yeah you can chunk each data set
can be chunked each chunk is stored as
not as a like an atomic piece so how you
choose to put those chunks together for
one data set or for one group or
whatever is up to the storage back-end
but each chunk of a data set is the
atomic piece that gets stored
[Music]
so the question is that hdf5
has a problem with appending data does r
have a similar problem or is this
intrinsic to chunking right so chunking
i'd say actually makes it easier to
append data importantly you can have
datasets that can be extended along
different dimensions so if you stored
like row-major data you might only be
able to add a new row but you couldn't
add a new column without copying
everything if you store it like to teach
unk's you can add rows and columns hdf5
has I would actually say doesn't I
actually have a big problem with rights
many people don't write efficiently it's
HD 5 so HD 5 well the data sets are
array like they have one extension which
is resize where you can grow a data set
so really what you're supposed to do is
like reason you should like resize very
aggressively like vector style like
double double double and then write
slices into it we have a very append
heavy workload with HD 5 and have found
it too so at different times I found
problems one issue is that writes all
happen at the chunk level so if you have
a lot of compression being applied it's
gonna be applied on every right another
reason you want to like batch up a big
write one thing we've done around that
is like batching like storing data in
memory and then trying to do like a
batch thing if you're using Tzar then
the the chunking or how the append
behavior works really depends on the
driver so in the zip file case every
time I add a new chunk we grow the zip
file by the size of that chunk but if
you were doing like an s3 store for
example every chunk is just gonna be a
unique object in s3 you can write like
as many of those in parallel while
there's really not gonna be any overhead
yes sir comments comments on cloud
object storage firs are but not for hdf5
the reason I don't comment on that as
before didn't talk about a lot is that
there is no default solution for that
that comes in the library this link
pass-through file driver for hdf5
is is that thing but because of the
single-threaded limitations it's
probably fine if you have a very large
multi-dimensional data set and you can
have one big read going into it a use
case that we've had is like I would like
to do the same read out of multiple data
sets and every read from hdf5 is
serialized behind the other one because
of the locking so it makes it hard when
every single read is really slow so
imagine it takes me like two
milliseconds to read or like 200
milliseconds to read or whatever because
it's like a lot of data I got to be
compress it if I could do 200
millisecond reads like five times in
parallel that's great if I have to
serialize all of them behind each other
it starts to look really really bad yeah
in hdf5 112 which is a new version they
actually have a new type of file system
hook that's gonna be called the virtual
object store instead of the virtual file
system or file driver and the idea is to
store with basically closer to the Tzar
model where you store key value pairs
and which represent the chunks but I
don't know when that comes out or that's
it was out I just learned about this day
so well it depends so things that need
to get the lock held is that there's a
chunky cache in HD of 5 so every time I
read a chunk and decompress it
I hold the decompressed version and a
cache and it's an LRU cache which is
configurable hd5 used to not be able or
each type I used to not have options to
configure that cache
the third-party library that exposed
those functions that probably changed a
few so it can be configured updating
that cache requires holding a lock so
that might be one reason where you can't
do that however I imagine they didn't
write the virtual object system without
considering this type of like new cloud
storage model so they may have relaxed
that requirement I'm not sure I'm
looking to it
okay well thank you very much
[Applause]